Vô lội vụ cho biết đang hoàn thiện dự thảo hiện định vê điều chính nước lương tối thiệu năm 2018,
tăng bình quân bày 29,5 sà với hiện hành và áp dụng từ ngày 1 một tháng 1 năm 2018,
vô dự kiến chính chính phổ trong tháng người này.
Theo bộ lội vụ, quy định vê nước lương tối thiệu đã được sách định gió trong bộ lợt lâu động.
Để là mức thấp nhất người sử dụng lâu động phải chả trong người lâu động,
làm công việc dành đơn nhất trong điều kiện bình thường,
nhưng bảo đảm mức sống tối thiệu của người lâu động,
phù hợp với khả năng của nền kinh tế.
Vềm đưa chính lương tối thiệu được thực hiện trên cơ sở quyền nghiệp của hội đồng tình đường
quốc gia sau khi xem sách chính phổ sẽ quyết định và công bộ mức lương tối thiệu mới cho tự vùng.
Chỉnh cơ sở báo cáo của hội đồng tình đường quốc gia về quyền nghiệp
phân án lương tối thiệu năm 2018, bộ nội vụ đang chù chỉ vối hợp với các bộ
ngành sách dự dự thảo nghiệp định quy định mức lương tối thiệu
đối với người lâu động làm việc theo hợp đồng lâu động.
Nội dụng này dự kiến chính phổ trong tháng người,
đều chính mức lương tối thiệu tăng bình quân bẩy phay phân chăm,
sau với mức hiện hàng,
áp dụng từ nay mong một tháng 1 năm 2018.